Jay and Silent Bob secret stash wants to
be your local comic shop has your local
comic shop closed down or is there no
local comic shop near you well guess
what Jay and Son Bob segerstash wants to
be your local comic shop so badly that
we've started an online reservist
program used to be coming to the store
and showing up get your books every
month now and anywhere in the
continental United States you can join
up our reservance program you get 15 off
every month you get 15 off your comic
books you get 15 off you trade
paperbacks you get 15 off your hard
covers and we send them right to you man
don't be Comics less what are you nuts
not when Jay and Silent Bob Seger stash
want to send you your Comics all you
have to do is go to secretstash online
and find the reserve a section and sign
up every month we will ship the books
right to you man from the world's most
famous comic book store Jay and Silent
Bob's secret stash go to secretstash
online right now or if you're on the
website just go down to the Reserva
section and sign up 15 off
are you waiting for let Jay and Silent
Bob send you comic books every month
kids